برلمان جديد في الكويت لم تختلف ملامحه عن
البرلمان السابق اذ حافظ غالبيه اعضائه
على مقاعدهم رغم تراجعي ترتيب بعض نواب
المعارضه حقق الاسلاميون والمقربون منهم
صعودا لافتا قوامه 12 مقعدا وكان فيه نصيب
الاخوان المسلمين سته مقاعد مقابل سته
للسلفيين بينما فاز المكون الشعيبي بخمسه
مقاعد ولاول مره نجحت حركه العمل الشعبي
في انتزاع مقعد النيابي من خلال مرشحها في
الدائره الرابعه متعب الرثعان بينما عاد
رئيس مجلس الامه السابق مرزوق الغانم برقم
كبير في دائرته الانتخابيه المراه
الكويتيه حصلت على مقعد واحد بعد ان كانت
تحظى بمقعدين في البرلمان السابق و بعكس
الانتخابات السابقه تميز هذا الاقتراع
باجواء يرى البعض انه تسلل اليها الاحباط
بسبب ابطال وحل تكرر كثيرا في السنوات
الاخيره اذا تكلمنا عن سنه تقريبا
المجلس ما بين حل وابطال حل وابطال يعني
من النادر ان يكمل مدته المجلس فهذا امر
طبيعي راح يكون راح ياثر او يسبب انعكاس
على المشاركه وعلى يعني
حاله
المشهد السياسي انه يكون هناك في احباط من
الناس تحديات واستحقاقات عده تواجه
البرلمان الجديد والحكومه التي سيعلن عن
تشكيلها لاحقا ما يتطلب تعاونا بين
السلطتين التنفيذيه والتشريعيه يجب ان
تكون
هناك بالكويت يجب ان تكون هناك حاله
استقرار سياسي يجب ان تكون هناك حاله من
التفاهمات بين البرلمان والحكومه الجديده
القادمه في الطريق
لان عدم التعاون وعدم الاستقرار السياسي
ايضا تنعكس سلبيا داخليا وخارجيا
نجح الناخب الكويتي في ايصال الشباب هذه
المره الى مقاعد البرلمان دون ان يغفل
شخصيات لها باع طويل في الحياه السياسيه
وتمثل رمزيه في الشارع الكويتي بينهم احمد
السعدون الذي يتوافق الجميع على عودته
رئيسا للبرلمان يطمح بعد اعلان نتائج
الانتخابات الى عوده التناغم بين السلطتين
التشريعيه والتنفيذيه ويتطلعون الى
استقرار سياسي يحقق تنميه لطالما انتظروها
طويلا سعد السعيدي الجزيره الكويت